this summoning of art and order
out of the products of the unconscious
is a kind of
open-ended task the shaman is
the archetype of the artist
the archetype of the creator the maker
homo faber the maker of tools
and i would argue that
in the same way that eliad in the forge
in the crucible
traces the evolution of
proto-metallurgic
shamanism into early smithing
and hence into the more fluoride
expressions that you get in
alchemical literature in the same way
that that was done by iliad it's
possible to argue
that you can carry that process forward
and see in fact
that the aspirations of the 20th century
in its most faustian expression the
manipulation of matter
the taking control of the weather uh
the splitting and releasing of the
energy in the atom
that these are all in fact uh
completions of explicitly defined
shamanic tasks it's just that somehow
the price of being able to work the
miracle
was literally loss of soul
by virtue of having to opt into the
metaphor that nature
it herself had no soul
in other words it's like a modern
man has made the journey into the realm
of the golam
in order to be in the realm of the golam
you must shed your own soul
and leave it behind you well
this is the cultural situation
that we inherit um
jean-paul sartre in uh
his major opus i think it was being and
nothingness
which sort of summed up 20th century
philosophy said
nature is mute that
is the existential situation well to me
this is like an apotheosis of
wrong-headedness
nature is not mute it must be
that man is death to hold
that position you see because
nature reinforces
uh the natural set of conclusions which
we tend to call feminine that
all things flow that nothing is
permanent
that form comes into being is sustained
and dissolves
that there is a kind of round
of eternal return that
worth is in the moment that it is
depth of felt experience
that empowers a life well lived
well these are things which are all
uh argued for by this
repressed point of view that has
survived
in modernism as only a thin
thread of tradition reaching back beyond
the collapse of the greco-roman world
to a time when these ideas actually
dominated and flourished
but i want to also talk about
what i think of as the
the shaman as model as
personal model um
the reason i think that shamanism is so
important is because i think what it
really boils down to
is a re-valuing of
personal identity and that when you
strip away the feathers and the chants
and all the anthropological
uh gim crackery that goes along with it
what makes it so compelling and so
attractive
is that it is a more authentic state of
being
somehow now why
it seems to me that the reason why is
because
theories about the world are based on
direct experience
the shaman is a kind of provisional
scientist making it up
as he or she goes along constantly
willing to revise and keep it open-ended
and information imported from without
is extremely suspicious
which is the exact opposite of the way
science for example does its work in
science
if you have a bizarre result or a
peculiar
finding you immediately say well go
check the literature
see if anyone else ever got this before
then get them on the phone and we'll see
if we can't duplicate
what they were doing
what this creates is what we have
which is a vast
low-grade inductively
derived image of reality
where only those things which happen
with the greatest regularity
and the greatest predictability are
authenticated by our languages
so we can talk about rain
and sunrise and meal time
and obligation because these things are
repetitiously before
us to the point where they have become
known as
smooth stones are known what is not
repetitiously before us
is the edge of cognition
the unique part of our own felt
experience
of reality and the reason for this
is very deeply rooted in the culture
it's that we
believe in these bizarre notions like
consensus like uniformity of phenomena
predictability probability
i mean everyone here believes in
probability who here could explain it to
the satisfaction of
anyone i mean we are adrift
and embedded in a matrix of unexamined
linguistic excuses for avoiding looking
at how weird it is
and that is what the shaman is not
the shaman first of all
basically has no real history cannot
consult vast
libraries is not in touch with
the reputations the overwhelming
stuffy reputations of his antecedents
hundreds of years in the past the
the shaman can usually ask one guy or
one woman
older than himself and that elder
represents the in what for us would be
an entire epigenetic
cosmos of data banks libraries
hieroglyphic records museum drawers
crammed with artifactry
so forth and so on so the shaman's
intellectual horizon in terms of what we
call historicity
is very foreshortened
consequently everything has to be
explained
out of energy that is unleashed in the
psyche
energy of speculation of myth making
of imagination and this is in fact then
what the function becomes
what the shamans are doing they are not
consuming
culture they are generating it
and herein lies the point for
us we must generate
culture rather than consume it to the
degree that we take this
ideal upon ourselves what
people say you know is it enough to just
clean up your diet i mean
how can we react in a in a
ever more stultifying political
environment
and i'm very loathed to try and deeply
answer that
because i don't trust myself i don't
know what i'm talking about
but it does seem to me that
the great weapon is art
because uh art is confusing
art hides a multitude of sins and can
serve many masters at once it is
subversive
it is cheap to produce and
if we take seriously the notion that
society is an
environment an ideological jungle
of competing memes then it's reasonable
to suppose
that the most articulately and clearly
constructed
myths will in fact come to be
but he he who can tell the best story
or she who can tell the best story will
see that story come to be
this is what the shamans are doing
for their societies they are exemplars
and this is a point that i want to make
very clearly
because i was published in the la
uh press as knocking
the venerable habit of using quartz
crystals
so i want to talk uh for a moment about
the shaman
as prestigitator the shaman as
showbiz and point out
that really what what shamans understand
is that the world is not as it appears
and this is big news everywhere
no culture is entirely comfortable
with the news that it's living in a
fool's paradise
but in the in the tribal situation where
sometimes living groups
number under a hundred and people are
living in let's say
an extreme environment like the highland
savannas of central asia or the amazon
jungle
there is a social cohesiveness that
brooks
no illusions about what people are
i mean it's pretty funky but
out of it comes the exemplar
the exceptional individual what we call
i believe intellectuals
and the intellectual is alienated
and sees more deeply into things than
everybody else because everybody else is
just
running around inside the cultural form
and it's very easy to run around inside
the cultural form and never to question
it
regardless of what it is
but the what in western society is
institutionalized as a vast
edifice of edge work
personified originally in the idea of
the universities
and then later in the idea of the
scientific and
and avant-garde artistic community this
this institution that empowers the
exploration of the unknown
in these tribal societies is boiled down
to just
one dude
or one woman and that person's
job is to push the envelope
to push the cultural envelope and to
come back
and report on strange things and to
confound
the political leaders and and to
control the weather and ensure good
hunting and work miraculous cures
and make everyone feel good about
themselves and
through the production of poetry dance
mask making chanting to give
permission for cultural evolution
to empower experiment to invite
people to journey into the cultural
self-image so so the
the shamans are really in a way micro
vectors for movement into the future
they are the anticipators at times i've
talked about shamanism as
a going between that the shaman is a
go-between
he or she negotiates between dimensions
negotiates the energy of one dimension
and the needs of one dimension
with the energies and needs of another
dimension
well but what exactly is this dimension
what is the source how of this
supernatural empowerment how seriously
can we
take it as we approach shamanism
if we approach it as anthropologists as
rationalists then how deeply
into it can we penetrate and maintain
those
conceits and what is it that forces
us to have to abandon them well i
maintain
that there is something in our worldview
that mitigates against us taking
seriously
the notion that the world is really made
of ideas
we have a great clinging
need to believe that the world is really
made of very solid
stuff this is our anxiety
this is a part of why the message of the
feminine
is so unwelcome because it says as
heraclitus said
pontetreya all flows
everything is in motion the hardest
truth there
is to learn is
that everything is lost
you know things come into being and then
they
leave being people children
marriages empires continents
species star systems they just come into
being
and they're fully there you know in the
poignancy
of the moment that absolute pristine
moment of fully realized being
and then they are replaced and
there is a constipated resistance to
this
in western society and yet
plunging into the depths of the felt
experience of the now
inevitably brings up this flowing river
the passing of the causal mechanisms
the rising and falling of sancharic
intent and
shamanism achieves this through
symbiosis
with plants i think that we have not
at all taken seriously enough
the notion that we are existentially ill
at ease
if we do not have symbiotic
relationships with plants
but in fact the thing which
distinguishes us from
other primates and most other mammals
is that we have this
apparently innate predilection
to addict
to everything to our mates
to territory to certain kinds of
food to behavioral patterns
of all sorts to sex
to structures of animosity
and when you get into talking about
fixations on
food you're moving very close to
the shamanic portal of discovery of
hyperspace which is of course
the the psychoactive properties of
plants
now there are two ways to talk about the
phenomenon of psychoactivity in plants
either as a kind of fortuitous
piece of good luck that
somehow um
the brain's ordinary dynamics are
chaotically disrupted by these
almost but not quite neurotransmitters
and out of the resulting chaos a still
higher level of brain
organization creates a wonderful myth of
meaning
and this myth of meaning can't be taken
seriously
because it's a interior description of
a pharmacologically induced state of
chaos you see this idea keeps saying
no meaning important to preserve the
concept
that there is no meaning in ecstasy
but the fact of the matter is that the
experience is almost entirely
epistemic and noetic it is not
chaotic chaotic is
is something that it appears to be to
the neophyte
and very few of its critics have ever
persisted into expertise
because it's much easier to slip away
and
write your informed denunciation
so it's very uh
so the other view is
that actually this constitutes
a true mystery the most
unlikely of all things that you might
hope or expect to encounter
that in fact what is called the ordinary
mundane world
is not ordinary or mundane at all
this long sought
meaning the super
expression of the transcendental
we all feel drawn toward
is in fact a realizable goal
that for whatever reason we have taken
upon ourselves
the pose or the stance
of seeker of one who looks for the
deeper level of things of one who really
wants to get to the bottom of things
in the phenomenon of shamanism
and the idea of taking it as a model you
have to confront the possibility
that these things can actually be
accomplished
that it is not
as orthodox traditions of all sorts
seem to insist which is that you can
only do it on tippy toes
and with bowed head and over 40 years
and
with a lot of uh discipline
and subservience that actually the older
model
of the chance-taking shaman
god's fool the dancer in the waterfall
is more authentic closer to the truth
that there really is transcendental
knowledge to be won
but there is no easy way
to it now i'm i got off on this tack
because i was discussing the
the show business aspect of shamanism
i think it is largely a pointing towards
something
and and the shaman is the trickster he
is the heyoka
and so the pertinences of shamanism
are the impertinences of a stage
magician
they do not convey or confer
anything except in the power in the
minds of those who observe
them in the amazon what i found that
really amazed me
was the more off river
and up country these guys were
in this case they were iowa scaros the
more
like pragmatic rationalists
they were you know they said well
you like you would say so what does this
mean when x y
and z happens and they say the people
believe
that it is the buzzabas say what do you
mean the people believe
said well that's what they believe he
said well what is it he said wolf
who knows what it is you know i mean
some of our best people
are working on it
[Laughter]
so there there was this understanding
that it is real exploration
that it is on the surface and that
hierarchy and dogma don't serve
well the reason this is so important
in trying to define a new context for
being human
is because we are mercilessly
worked over by informational hierarchies
that disempower us
but take away from the power
of our immediate experience a
a specific and lead pipe
example of this is the the suppression
of psychedelics
psychedelics are suppressed because
they dissolve cultural preconceptions
it's just that simple dissolving
cultural preconceptions
is not something the establishment is
into fostering
of course not but
what is so maddening is if you look at
the world
as we have inherited it you see
that we have the food
to feed everyone we have the resources
to deliver a comfortable life to
everyone
what is required is a change of mind
change of mind we need to change our
mind
and this is something which people hate
to do but i think very few people go
through life without
having to do it at some point or another
and you know it's actually quite
painless and
you can really get into it
you just say you know i said i'd never
do that
so now i'm doing it
it's very clear that we must change our
minds
and the beginning of it must come from
the high-tech
industrial democracies the average
person on this planet
is black young
female third world
and poor that's who's waiting
for the honky world to get its ass
together
and we are at the top of a very narrow
cultural pyramid
that has been tolerated
only restlessly to this point
and as a global informational culture
begins to take place people are finding
out what the score
is and so it becomes incumbent upon
everyone
to change their mind and this is
understood everywhere in the corporate
boardrooms in the military
planning centers everywhere the question
is
how shall we change our minds shall we
turn ourselves
into a can and barbie society of
consumeristic robots
unquestioningly following some boiled
down
ideology that is essentially one
of unquestioned loyalty unending
consumption unending toleration of
stupidity
this is one point of view it's a point
of view which
fears people
it's an aristocratic oligarchic
point of view the notion that you know
the mob must be controlled if not opium
television if not that pornography
always holding human nature at bay
seeing it
as something which if ever unleashed
would roll over the more delicate
sensitivities of a master class
or can there be
a return to partnership
a return to work on what has been
spoiled
by the father which means internal work
on the misogyny which is inherent in the
most self-congratulatory and enlightened
bastions of the new age
[Music]
a world where there is a sense of global
responsibility
you